coco you're sitting back you're watching
all this i'm watching how are you
processing all this what are your
thoughts on her perspective
well
people can do whatever they want
obviously her
marriage is her thing and if that works
for her that's totally fine
i think that
you know if something happens let's say
actually i need to understand first what
do you what did what does he do for work
and did you do something for work before
so i met him when i was in the military
i worked underneath him as a medic so a
medical screener he is a medical
provider within the military he's a
physician's assistant i had a job but
then we ended up having a conversation i
was like
why am i working and he was like okay
facts and that was pretty much the end
of it and now i make content on youtube
so i get to do a job that i enjoy
okay so i mean if that works for them
that's totally fine i just see a lot
when when a woman completely abandons
her life i'm not saying that's you but
i'm saying in general when a woman
completely abandons her life and she is
just
a wife or just um
like you don't have anything yours going
for you and how how do you know okay you
are married but like how do you know
that this is gonna be forever because
marriages do fall apart i'm not saying
yours will but
um i i had a situation in my life when i
was just somebody's girlfriend and i was
so happy
at the
a few months in
but then later i just realized for me
that's not enough and i want people to
remember me for me and not for being
somebody's plus one
god so you want to respond to that do
you think that you would have felt
better about that situation had you been
that man's wife instead of the
girlfriend
no
maybe it's just the person
but
um i just me personally like i left my
hometown when i was 22. i came to the
states alone
and if i wanted a life where i'm just
gonna be somebody's wife and i'm
there's a lot of women who are totally
fine with that and i have a lot of
friends who just housewives and
that is a really tough job and raising
kids is really difficult and that being
like you be with them all the time it's
not easy but for me i just wanted
something more and i just wanted one i
mean
at the time there wasn't like youtube i
mean there wasn't like tick-tock and
stuff when i was in that relationship
but
i it was not enough for me well why
don't we do this so so the audience is
crystal clear on what you guys stand for
essentially and we'll have a you know
deeper conversation go down the line
here
uh start with you coco you talk about
raising the women's standards what's
your
you know goal as a woman where do you
think the role of a woman should be and
then we'll go down the line here to ally
and pearl well women have a lot of roles
you can't just say a woman has like what
a woman has one role and she should just
like live in that role i mean
my my whole thing about raising your
standards is like don't just marry the
first guy you kind of like because you
think that your clock is sticking or
because you think that you
are not whole because you don't have
that missing piece or something like why
do women think that the highlight of
their existence if they're somebody's
wife i don't think that's true i mean
some people decide not to get married
and they're happily ever after but you
just don't have the piece of paper
so
i don't know if that answers your
question okay i got it ally go ahead i'm
just trying to address a lot of fear
because i hear that argument a lot well
if you're just a wife you're going to
lose yourself but if we keep feeding
women this narrative like they're going
to eat it up and they're they're going
to buy it but if you have a man who can
protect provide and cherish you it's
like no it's a no-brainer of course
you're going to go ahead and pursue
something like that but women are always
thinking oh i lose something in a
marriage i lose something in a marriage
i'm vulnerable i don't think so i think
men take the bigger risk in assuming all
of the responsibility for finances
within a marriage if you look at the
divorce statistics it's pretty cut and
dry so like uh sometimes i hear
you know what happens if your husband
leaves you for someone younger i
actually don't worry about that because
i know how the family courts are it's
more so the fact that like my
women women's satisfaction in marriage
we have a lot more autonomy over that
than we think because we end up leaving
most of the time i think 80 of the time
women are the ones causing the divorce
it's 90 of your college educated wow
okay so pearl weigh in on this go ahead
because you've been kind of quiet you've
been waiting but you what you do is you
red pill women so are you married or no
no i'm not married okay are you in a
serious relationship right now or no i'm
not you're not okay so we have a single
woman we have a married woman and a
woman in a relationship relationship but
not married we couldn't ask for a better
panel ladies and gentlemen shout out to
our booker here go ahead pearl
i'm sorry what was the question yeah
just basically what you stand for what i
stand well i grew up um
in a more like traditional family and i
really appreciated it that like my goal
is to get married and i think my life
like it wouldn't be complete if i didn't
have a husband and family like that's
how i feel about it so you're saying
your goal is to get married yes okay
that's your goal
yeah i mean i have other goals too like
what are your other goals um my other
goals i want to hit a hundred thousand
subscribers on youtube so you guys
should help me out help her out
just pearl right just pearly things just
pearly things let's get that going all
right so number one on your list is
marriage number two is is that a career
yeah okay so the career is in a backseat
to
marriage yeah okay and ali for you is
was marriage number one on your list my
dream in life was to be a housewife and
to do some work some kind of work from
home so i would say like i made it i
made it you're living your best life
living my best life all i'm missing is
the babies they're coming next are they
coming next oh yeah yeah we just bought
a house so we have to fill it with
humans you know you gotta fill that with
humans can i can i actually add some
shirts to my my dad is like a top one
percent like he's very very successful
and my mom was actually supposed to be a
teacher and she quit that to go work for
my dad and they ended up building like a
multi-million dollar business and having
10 kids
and kids yeah and 10 kids so i you're
one of ten yeah i'm one attack what does
your dad do um so he owns a software
company got it and i just think that you
know
in order to accomplish anything there's
always going to be risk
and i got to see the benefits of my mom
taking that risk like it might not have
worked out she had to move to him she
had to leave her school and quit her job
but
so your dad is a owner of a software
company your mom was going to be a
teacher she was a teacher and she said
you know what let me jump off the
teaching trail i'm going to go work for
my boss who also is my husband and it
worked out well yeah okay now coco is
what's your goal is it your goal is your
top goal to be a wife to be married
what's your top goal my top goal is to
create
a company i mean my goal is to i work i
used to study journalism so i love the
media world and i currently am starting
a podcast so i want to work in the media
space but i want this to be my thing and
i want this to be something that nobody
can take away from me so like if
if i'm somebody's wife one day he can
just be like okay well what if he what
if he bankrupts or something then what
your life is over if you don't have
anything that you're doing on the side
but i also feel like you're not just a
housewife because you are doing your
content correct
but that pales in comparison to the work
that i did before like it's it's a night
and day difference you said you were in
the army yes i was in the united states
military okay yeah a lot of women
they'll talk about you know like working
hard working hard i'm like have you been
to the woods for 30 days on end like no
shower and not enough food it's not fun
so i would say you know yes i work and i
do content creation i'm gonna be real if
you're intelligent and you can figure
out a business model and you can figure
out what people want to hear to it to an
extent i do like to provide value
because i don't want to sell women a lie
if you can do that i mean work smarter
not harder you can really reduce your
work hours so i my husband does so much
for me and i don't want to act like that
my channel would be possible if i did it
myself it's not true like i would refer
to him as like my primary financier for
my channel like he makes the platform
happen and i'm proud of that but you
still work though like you work for your
content so you're not just the housewife
coco it's not a hard job but it was not
a hard job content creation
for me
so you think it is a hard job is that
what you're saying i think it is
different because this is your full-time
gig yeah you're a content creator
full-time yeah your full-time job is
being a housewife slash
content creator but first job is being a
housewife yes well i mean even if you're
just like if you say just a housewife
like you're still creating culture
like you don't you don't understand what
goes into that like my mom had
traditions that we did every single year
to being a mom like my mom is a great
mom she always worked and she always she
raised me and my brother
like really well i would say
and she always worked but she also had
time to raise us
i know why do we reduce it to like just
the housewife no i didn't say this you
said that earlier okay maybe i don't
remember
well a lot a lot of women do that you
know just a housewife just a housewife
actually i'm sorry sorry to cut you off
i actually said i'm not saying that
that's i actually said that being a
housewife is a difficult job and raising
kids is a difficult i said that so maybe
i don't know what i mean
but it's probably still something that
like should be addressed because women
wouldn't feel like they were just a
housewife if they married you know the
wholesome chad that they wanted in the
first place and that's where you know my
channel comes in because women get a lot
of bad dating advice and it's like
dating advice that teaches you how to
date but it doesn't teach you how to you
know hopefully get married and stay
married like that's it like all they can
do is get you a date well not every guy
that takes you out for a meal is looking
to commit and that's that's a big
problem that i see i think millennial
and gen z women were really left behind
by gen x mothers i got i had a bone to
pick with them with gen x mothers oh
yeah they're they're like the kraft mac
and cheese generation they suck they did
not set their daughters up well why go
go deeper on that how do you mean well
you can you can just tell it so it
started with the baby boomer generation
and then i want to say the gen x but
then
baby boomers were rebellious against the
silent generation they thought they were
old fashioned they thought they were you
know too set in their ways with
the woodstock generation the baby
boomers exactly yeah yeah and so you get
like these gen x mothers they are so
narcissistic and they think that you the
daughter you're just gonna find a man i
lived in my my house with my mother for
19 years and not once did the
conversation come up you know what is a
good wife what is a good husband how do
you find one and i started asking my
other girlfriends when i had like a an
epiphany i think i was 25 i started
asking them like did your mother ever
talk to you about this and most of them
are telling me no that it wasn't a
conversation so that's kind of how i've
been able to figure out that like yeah
gen x mothers y'all did us dirty for
sure
a word that is popping into my head is
the concept of fear
like
you're fearful that because you were you
said that you were a stay-at-home
girlfriend no no i never said that no
you said you didn't do you said you were
girlfriend didn't do anything that's
exactly what you said
i never said that what did you say no i
said at some point in my life i was
dating somebody and i was his girlfriend
right but i i did i still worked okay
well i thought your job was a bigger
apology
but
part of what i'm understanding you tell
me if i'm crazy here if i'm spot on
is the fear that if you don't have a
career
the fear of well my man could leave me
or i don't have a fallback plan
and it seems like and rightfully so
you're fearful of that so you want to
have your own career whereas ali is like
yeah i get it that is a fear but i'm not
gonna let that get in the way of me
being a good wife and being kind of more
submissive do i have that right or am i
going crazy
i'm not building my career because i'm
scared and my boyfriend's going to leave
me
okay so why are you building your career
because i want to be successful and i
want to pursue my dreams and my dream is
to
be a media person so let me ask so
i'll get back to that now is feared did
i use this word correctly is that do you
think women have this fear yeah but it's
a made-up fear it's a boogeyman fear
family courts are going to favor women
astronomically and then i've had women
come out and they're like well i got
divorced and i didn't didn't get
anything my first question is who filed
so you're mad that you decided to leave
him and then you couldn't get his money
like i'm sorry i don't feel bad for you
if it was that if that if those
resources were that important to you you
could have worked it out and that's not
to speak on relationships where there's
dv involved okay like everybody knows
that's wrong again a boogeyman concept
but what do you say dv domestic violence
oh gotcha right i'm trying to al
algorithm yeah i didn't realize that was
a okay and you can always just get a job
after you get divorced like it's not
like you're you're banned from working
just because you're a little bit older
like i built this youtube channel like i
started a show three months ago and i
got 30 000 subscribers this month like
boom how'd that happen what you work
hard and i could i could do that at 45
too
so i don't know why like if you get
divorced you can still get a job